I've seen this firefighter that got
fired for her Instagram posts no shield
lifetime piece she's uh she's so built
like in a good way I got a girl does she
have a huge [ __ ] hey bro
cuz if not gallons out well let me see
take a look at some of these posts
nothing bad right so she's wearing her
attractive the great diamond she's
pretty and then here's one right that's
either actual cheeked up your actual
regular some on fire
hey chic does she put out put out a fire
with them cheeks there's a regulation
firemen pant that's it that's a that's a
fire my parent man take it easy dude I
got this hose in my bag she's a [ __ ]
wait what's the problem here we got fire
for some of those posts and I'll post
some of those posts what was wrong with
them she had like over 20-something
complaints fire higher else then what a
bunch of [ __ ] but then you know there's
no one with hurt if I don't she's a male
counterparts would post you know
shirtless pics not enough and they're
fine
what she's suing is so she's doing that
Montana Montana if I was in Montana
that's really good she doesn't she won't
be great guys that's why if I was doing
a gig in Montana to set the club on fire
literally on fire so she would come oh
there's every girl super built I did
she's bad she's at that Bill chin she's
just hot as [ __ ] do a climber agreed no
did she come on just a lien a stallion
for uten that's just [ __ ] stock cheat
yo [ __ ] up man you say hey Montana calm
the [ __ ] down
she's got a gun but I smack me around
change probably look that is built
yeah it's bail she's hot man man not
your type Jim because she she's too much
for me a mustache that's too much for
that's why your game
I can't either but I'll step up step up
and put in the old [ __ ] 53 year old
college try
I mean her should have kids yeah you
guys should give world room look at this
oh my god I mean I'll try but she's out
Stan I'd be longer her goddamn job back
she's suing now ah she should let me
know it yeah she needs help with the
lawyer if you would ever need a morale
boost if you need some sort of can heat
an old cotton you can toss around like a
baton like a circus baton well I'm gonna
set up a [ __ ] showing mine look at
that throw me around like a circus
boishakh can you hold the camera god
yeah what it says Virginia though chin
well that's part we just took that's a
female friend a job right there like
that look at her with a mask on that's a
hot dog fader right there he sure she's
in Montana chick yeah the the fire
departments like evergreen fire recipe
she's like Anna she's a Jets fan chances
probably class and Italian and Armenian
somebody's just so surprised Dagestan II
she's a firefighter from heaven yes she
is dude yes she is so I mean the posts
aren't that crazy all right they're just
crazy hot save me look at her shooting
there she's got arms on her she's got
arms to that your arms an I do
I got [ __ ] I'm just um I'm pissed off
you know what I always wanted to make me
fall just yep
Oh before she had like 80,000 now it's
like 160 so you know I always wanted to
be there's more than that I agree I
always wanted to be husky I always
wanted to have the kind of body but guys
go hey Bryce bright beefy husky I want
to be beefy and I never will be good
night
wanna be be okay so Taylor Swift just
came out with her documentary on Netflix
and there's a short clip about the
reason why she took a five-year hiatus
and Nikki Glaser was actually in there
and it was talk she was on a show
talking about how she thought Taylor
Swift was too skinny did it yeah it was
exactly Liz oh it was in a much older
interview and she ended up actually
posting a photo wearing Tillis whoops
merch apologizing for it right
oh you don't want them Swifties after
you yeah but she got she got the cosine
I saw this my girl hit me up about this
that's how I know and she basically just
apologized and said that whatever she
said in that interview was projection of
what was going on in her life she
apologized taylor swift saw it and
actually reached out to her oh that's
cool I like okie good you know thank you
I do nothing great yeah yeah yeah she's
l2 that's a nice little uh that's a nice
that's a nice cloud chase right there
well I appreciate so much one of the
major things that thoughts that we have
ability to change their pins over time
grow I'm so sorry to hear that you
struggle with some of the same things
I've seen and massive hug hashtag none
of my fans buy a ticket to her show wow
that's cool way to go did you say there
will be one person - she's so goddamn
powerful yeah I mean like if you go out
to Beyonce and the B I think they're
called the Beehive yeah dude they'll
shut your [ __ ] down yeah yeah yeah watch
your P's and Q's it Beyonce yeah the the
tail is so [ __ ] maybe she was right
maybe she was too skinny I mean didn't
tell us oh she's always been too skinny
to me hold on until Association she was
battling disorder so that she used to be
a size double zero and now she's a size
six in the documentary I'm just saying
that like the more she saw photos of
herself the more she realized that she
didn't like the way she looked so she
just slowly kind of stopped so Nikki
Glaser's right so she's skinny you
looked at the photos you agreed you
change your life what the nice
apologizing for Nikki
you just saved your favorite singer
Nikki doesn't this white thing Nikki's
bodied up to that's why though Nikki's a
great job but here's a yeah why are we
upset about this like that's weird some
of fat shaming or skinny shaming like if
you're saying someone's too skinny this
won't get you say some was too skinny
it's shame if you say someone's too fat
its shame yeah but both of them are just
pushing you towards the direction of
health
they're also observations right like
when once if someone thinks I've posted
patreon Oh some people for content but
the bag god damn you're fast [ __ ] shop
yeah you don't think my ass is on the
bike late afternoon like the motivation
so just [ __ ] motivate
don't think of [ __ ] but doing deliveries
like a Mexican ass boy yeah Doug
fashioned their bike you for offering
off kotoba you've always been skinny huh
you just stay there you gotta flip a
[ __ ] combo professional like you do
professional bra not anything yeah do
you know the bread that refined sugars
youth in any way yeah my look then I'm
at then I'm an otter dog did you guys
see the Super Bowl halftime show
yes well whose otter JLo Shakira it's
Shakira by a million [ __ ] miles dude
no waiting clothes JLo is wearing a
[ __ ] maxi pad during her entire
performance you see that the wings were
flapping out the sides and I couldn't
even look at her ovaries you look
everyone room for Sierra yeah because
you have to understand what's going on
okay I'm in a relationship all right
okay what I'm thinking I'm not fit you
guys are thinking about JLo you're
thinking about legacy you're thinking
about all these are debating about
busting nuts doggystyle who do you think
it's gonna make the nuts bus did you see
Shakira's hips telling the truth tell
the truth all that shake boom pop pop
pop pop so tiny bro that's the thing
like that Cameron oh yeah oh yeah she
went for it
she went for now here's the thing is
this it that's the thing yeah [ __ ]
wasn't good you know who she was talking
to [ __ ] Isis broke do I really does
by the way a terrorist attack at the
Super Ball is like Yoshi's signal in
this jail has on that thick makeup dude
did look JLo is starting bodied the [ __ ]
done
she's bided too [ __ ] up I think Aaron
Rodriguez got her on some [ __ ] because
she wasn't like this before Aaron no
Aaron a rod a rod a chubby bull these
days he's shall eat Rodriguez algae in
the face now yeah he might might be a
little chubby fan my point is this
Shakira for one [ __ ] one night of
[ __ ] look at the hip thing you're not
gonna experience that any
you're not gonna experience that
anywhere else you don't how many big
dudes
JLo has [ __ ] go through the list Ben
Affleck P Diddy [ __ ] everybody Drake
so great when you're bang with Shakira
but when you're [ __ ] ago you're
thinking about like what guy she's
holstered oh yes why cuz I'm a freak son
so you're banging it and you're like
[ __ ] Diddy was in here like that was
crossed my mind cuz me and it'd be like
the same cars
so if did he took that first I want to
take you for a spin
I see now that's weird see I don't want
to think about Diddy when I'm having sex
not think about him I just go okay only
time I think about Diddy when I'm on sex
is when I'm looking at a ground I go
take that take take take that take that
take that take that the old ads look at
Shakira dude the way she moves her hips
and it doesn't work in the pictures in
the pictures you're gonna look at JLo
but when you look a location believes it
hoes it's about the way she moves the
hit I agree it's not even a question
like you're talking about a unique
sexual experience with that one girl on
the left it is a truly unique experience
she's tiring though she's fiery hips are
moving like crazy don't lie it's gonna
be a different thing your dick never
experienced that in your life JLo
beautiful girl a thousand of hers I mean
you could get it right percent unless
I'm not gonna ride a dick ain't better
than any other girl from the Bronx I
don't know
Oh cardi beats from the Bronx right you
think cardi can't take it down more than
JLo that's what I'm saying you know who
could give cardi run for our money
Shakira right there that Colombian mommy
it's and I kinda have a job right now
listen do you a little bit she's going
keep going okay if you got any gifts or
any movement of the hips you would see
what's going on you're just gonna lay on
your back you don't do you lay on your
back you give Shakira the whole night
with her on top you don't even try to
[ __ ] on top you lay on your back and
then she goes to work lazy all night
it's not about lazy it's about you
giving her that back you're right dude
but you got to let her work I mean oh
it's just different
she's just tiny so look look just a
little amazing there's no meat on either
one of them they're super skinny no
Jayla has a little bit of
ah here's the other thing hey here's the
other thing what's the other landed
titties not become cool anymore
everybody flat-chested these days that's
true you like some do you like some jugs
I like like huge knob is really four
years old man I like like [ __ ] Beth
Chapman like Doug body on her tits you
know it's such a reverence just how this
out my one of my weird one of my dear
friends in high school
he only had his mom and he always said
that my dad never knew my dad my dad
walked out on me and he was like [ __ ]
just the craziest athlete we'd ever seen
in in high school and he was like yeah
my mom told me my dad was a bodybuilder
or whatever whatever but I remember
always feeling bad for my friend because
his dad had he'd never knew his dad
crazy his mom was a nurse he had no
money all that so he he's 50 or whatever
he's through his whole life and he does
it 23andme because it was given to him
as a Christmas things like whatever the
[ __ ] this guy finds out he's got like
three sisters two brothers and his dad
was always in the picture his dad was a
hot was a calculus teacher a high school
calculus teacher a great guy then became
a principal and never knew he had a son
because he's his mother
um yes and his mother just never told us
the plot Joe the man never [ __ ] knew
he had a son
and so his his brothers and sisters
looked him up and went hey and now he's
got this relationship and they're like
well you know it's all this he's like I
could have used the guy and he died of a
heart attack the year before that's he
was in his car and he died of a heart
attack but it was crazy because he was
like that was my men his egos my our dad
would have loved to have had another son
if he had known you such an athlete
anyway it's neither dead I remember that
I was like what is a stir when you see
my
I pull myself up like a champ like a
chimp through 30 times fast while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a get it's a gift it's a gift